on just three days rest here is charlie
morton well you look at that bottom don
four and one record and series clinching
games the reason he's out there brian
snicker said look i'm gonna check with
him inning by innings see how he's
feeling now first and second oh for 16
this series is this where they can break
through 2-2
balance by him so he comes back with a
98 mile an hour fastball yell at tardy
on the swing two on one away and that
brings up abacio garcia
off the plate chopped towards third
austin riley comes in bare-handed makes
the throw and it's in time
nice play by austin riley do or die
bare-handed and he makes it to get
garcia
as two will advance long to third to
dominance to second but nice play by
austin reilly hold for 18 as it stands
right now rowdy toles
struck him out out of the jam is charlie
morton in the first inning on the mound
one of the best kept secrets of the
second half of the season is eric lauer
on the mound for the brewers 24 games 20
starts but the last 15 games six and two
with a 2.23 and opponents only hit 188
against them a double the start tanks
here in the bottom of the first inning
for dansby swanson here's freddie
freeman
in the air to right center field lorenzo
kane the center fielder gets himself
ready
to make the catch swanson's going to try
it here comes the throw and he will be
safe
throws off the mark a good throw i think
gets him
got him
big strikeout for lauer it's out number
two of the first inning first strikeout
for lauer is swanson at third base fly
ball right field abacio garcia's got
room
shy of the track will make the catch it
ends the inning the braves leave swanson
at third
2-2 from lauer
loop to shallow left incoming is yellow
she'll make the running catch
and he can turn this into a double play
as they flip to second base and often
trying to score from second was duvall
he was two bases away
so they turned that into a double play
he works to his first hitter of the
third inning he is back on three days
rest
that is strike three fourth strikeout
for charlie morton first out of the
third inning willie adams has had a good
series he is five for 13 with a single
by him
back-to-back strikeout for morton he's
got five in all 2-2
on the ground to third to the backhand
is riley plants and throws inning over
two and a half done from atlanta in game
four we're scoreless there's one out in
the third that's a green grass in the
left center 3-2
got him second strikeout for lowry
strikes out swanson for out number two
of the third inning freddie freeman he's
in second with two down here's ozzy
albee's
popped up
right side and it's rowdy toles who
steps into foul ground and makes the
catch
that sends us to the fourth inning in
game four of the nlts
singles for garcia starts things in the
fourth and here is rowdy toled
fly ball in the air to right field as
jack peterson moves over
has plenty of room and makes the catch
for out number one go see it's second
urea first one out in the brewers fourth
inning lamar narvaez coming up here
line to left center field that's in for
a base hit
abacio garcia is coming around from
second base here comes the throw play
word he will be
safe and the brewers take a one-nothing
lead finally get a big hit for the
runner in scoring position and driving
it in is narvaez he ends up at second
base with the throw plate and the
brewers take a one-nothing lead and
right here another big moment for the
milwaukee brewers you got the one run
you finally broke open the runners and
scoring position
oh for 20 now one for 21. chavez the
stretch in the pitch swinging line drive
base hit up the middle that's going to
score at least one as narvaez holds at
the last moment kane delivers it's two
nothing brewers riley with a lead at
first
duvall pops it up
foul ground over is the catcher narvaez
and he can't make the catch but urias
does the third baseman was right in the
neighborhood and makes the grab before
it hits the grass oh and raves gonna
challenge us that may have hit the dirt
first i think he may have it looks like
it doesn't it yep it is being challenged
by brian snicker
i don't think it's overturned there
could be one possibility here is that
that is not one
that's the only thing i can guess
because to me you saw the bases yeah
that that first and third and so it's
unrevealed
rosario is going to pinch hit here 349
in his career with the bases loaded
broken back signal into center field
from third comes riley here comes
darnold he will score this game this
time
broke his back
but throw it into center field to tie
the ball game up so now first and third
two down brings up dansby swanson
to third and picked by eures who throws
the second one to play
luis urrias on an exploding ball at
third base comes up with it fires to
second for the fourth shot that ends the
inning one down one on and it brings up
rowdy celeste
you see it a two-run home run in
milwaukee
in game one that helped the brewers
secure the first game of the series here
it is and rowdy sends one in the air to
center deep get up get up get out of
here and gone
for rowdy teles
and the brewers back on top
he hit one out of here in the center and
way out of here
and the brewers right back on top
bases loaded one out and jacques
peterson old for two
on the ground left side urias will cut
it off flips to second for one it's late
at first to run scores
in the back door comes all bees and it's
a one run game it's now four to three
and the ending continues
for
travis darno
on the ground by the first baseman into
right from third base comes riley
two-third goes peterson and this game is
tied at four travis darneau drives in
the tying run for atlanta
first and third with two down
in the braves sixth inning and austin
riley coming up
on the ground slowly hit urias racing in
from third bases
in time and out of the jam is brandon
woodruff nicely done for the milwaukee
brewers two down in the eighth freddy
freeman
first pitch and a fly ball deep center
going back kane at the wall that is good
first pitch and he sends a shockwave
through the ballpark and they're going
crazy here in atlanta
he is a dangerous dangerous man
and he's high-fiving everyone down in
that first base dugout i've never seen
him celebrate so much here is christian
yelich with two outs and the brewers
down to their last out
freddie freeman and the atlanta braves
are heading to the national league
championship series
they have eliminated the milwaukee
brewers
and they win here in atlanta in front of
40 000 strong
and this place is going crazy here in
atlanta
nichola vulture organic seltzer as real
as it tastes